moi je faire plus court j'ai un message
pour vous si les mourne d'importance
j'entends partout dire chaos européen
schengen l'europe a échoué et c'est
chaque fois qu'on critique l'europe aux
critiques soi même on critique son
propre gouvernement d'elaia matière donc
ne criez pas avec les loups écriront
toujours plus fort que vous ne dites pas
schengen doit être changé et c'est les
accords de schengen marcherait s'il
était appliqué
le problème c'est qu'ils ne le sont pas
ce sont surtout les accords de dublin
pourrait techniquement l'expliqué j'ai
pas le temps c'est à dire ceux qui font
que la grèce l'italie la hongrie doivent
protéger les frontières de l'union
mais l'idée de la libre circulation à
l'intérieur de l'europe celle là c'est
pas celle qui pose un problème
la france n'a pas tellement un problème
de réfugiés elle risque de la voir dans
les jours qui viennent
elle a un problème d'immigration
économique
si vous regardez les chiffres nous avons
un problème d'immigration d'afrique y
compris d'afrique du nord avant d'avoir
un problème de réfugiés
donc je dis ça pourquoi parce que un
grand parti qui prépare l'alternance
il doit faire des propositions concrètes
vous avez commencé vous allez continuer
et des propositions concrètes c'est à
dire schengen est à jeter l'europe est
importante et c'est fait des
propositions concrètes et les
propositions concrètes c'est comment
renforce nos frontières extérieures
comment on fait face aux 4 millions de
personnes qui sont au liban en syrie en
jordanie etc en turquie et qui vont
vouloir venir en europe
au passage s'ils viennent en europe ils
vont pas ailleurs quand même dire qu'on
vit pas si mal que ça ici donc soyez
dans la vie politique
soyez dans la vie politique française ce
qui sont concrets qui passent pas leur
temps à débiner l'europe qui fait rêver
à l'extérieur il n'y a pas de raison de
désespérer à l'intérieur soyons concret
ou
il faut réformer ses traités oui il faut
faire face à cette vague d'immigration
sans précédent il faut le faire en
respectant le droit français on vous l'a
expliqué avant le droit international le
droit d'asile et dans la constitution
française article 4 du préambule de la
constitution de 46 faut-il la réviser et
cetera faut-il en préciser les contours
fait le ménage à 90 au n'est pas l'air
de marine le pen qui est de dire c'est
schengen c'est l'europe d'abord schengen
c'est pas l'europe
ça a été fait une initiative franco
allemande qui est devenue communautaire
après et puis moi je veux pas vivre dans
un monde où les capitaux les biens les
services les marchandises peuvent
circuler librement et il ya que les
personnes qui se heurtent à des murs il
faut donc être concret précis être
finalement ceux qui plaident pour une
implication plus forte de la france en
europe on le fera peut-être pas à 28
faisons le déjà en franco allemand ça ne
marche pas allez-y allez-y critiqué
l'inaction du couple franco-allemand de
la france qui doit être à l'initiative
elle est attendu partout en europe pour
prendre l'initiative et nous serons un
exemple vous pouvez être cela ne ratez
pas la chance